something i noticed just before we came
on air today and let me give you a quick
setup here okay this the la rams are
very good about sending out transcripts
of all press conferences and what i try
to do and i get transcripts from most of
the teams i'll skim through them to see
if there's something in there that's
newsworthy something that we need to
talk about on the show maybe something
we need to find and play
and i saw the todd gurley transcript
yesterday
and based upon his answers i got the
vibe he wasn't real happy
so i decided i'll go watch this because
he's giving real short answers and
sometimes the answer is in parentheses
shakes head no right so i i just seemed
like he's not real thrilled with what's
going on he had a career low five
carries on sunday even though the rams
scored 40 points so and and part of the
context is he's averaging 15 touches per
game last year through four games he was
averaging close to 25 a game the year
before that when he won nfl offensive
player of the year he averaged 26.5
touches per game the first four weeks so
he's no longer the workhorse so i went
and watched the video
and there's some stuff at the tail end
that didn't make its way into the
transcript
and here's what happened i'll tell you
the question then we'll play the rest of
it yeah the question was
you're playing alternating series is
this a coach's decision is this a
player's decision are you okay and
here's what todd gurley had to say
i think i've asked you you asked this
question before so take the answer i
gave you last time
i don't remember you i don't remember
giving you a question either
that is a salty todd gurley and i can't
blame him look he's going through some
stuff right now he's no longer a
workhorse tailback he's no longer one of
the great players in the nfl he's
getting paid that way and i think he
realizes that sooner rather than later
he may not be getting paid that way but
that whole three-minute press conference
it was that same vibe but they left out
that part at the end where he's asked
specifically is it coach's decision or
your decision to play alternating series
and yeah you you've asked that question
before and it's the same answer so hey
look it's been about the knee all year
long it's been about his usage all
season long and the rams try to put the
best possible face on it they try to act
like everything's fine but clearly chris
it's not fine no i mean clearly it's not
i mean you if he you know again if it's
the a guy that we know is capable of
being the best running back in football
and he was totally 100 healthy
there wouldn't be alternating series you
just don't do that i mean no you let a
guy that's completely healthy and can be
dominant you let him keep running the
ball and doing you know special things
that we've seen todd gurley do so
there's obviously an issue there i wish
they would kind of just address it and
be honest with it at this point it's not
like any of us don't know okay i mean
we're past that point and nor is it
going to quiet down until you do address
it until he has a game wait for it wait
for it oh like a workout workhorse
tailback or we see him go 60 and 70 yard
runs like we did two years ago or at the
start of last year and that so none of
that is going to go away and i do feel
bad for todd gurley that he's got to
deal with this and it's not easy and all
that that's why i wish i really think it
would be easier if they would just be
open and honest about it and just take
it head on and yeah i got a knee issue
and yeah we're managing it as a team and
myself personally and we're trying to
work through it and see where it takes
us i mean it's as simple as that i don't
understand why we got to like act like
there's nothing wrong
yeah i i i agree with that completely
now the one theory would be that
that maybe they're saving him for later
in the year sure but but here's the
thing
if you if you play well enough to get to
the postseason
using the offense where todd gurley is a
role player not a workhorse why would
you change in january right like you're
gonna suddenly suddenly alter the
identity of your offense just because
you're at the point where you think you
can trust todd gurley to carry the ball
25 times a game and then what if he
can't you're screwed right no you're
exactly right it's very rare to see a
team change formula like that especially
as they get closer to playoff football
uh and last week i know he didn't touch
the ball the game didn't dictate it
either i mean they got down in a hole
early because of the interceptions the
turnovers and then they had to throw the
ball to come back
all right that's it for wednesday we're
off tv on thursday we'll be back friday
everybody have a great day see ya
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports